it doesn't matter in which zip code you
are born at it doesn't need to dictate
the trajectory of your life and I think
that you know it may be made me the
entrepreneur I am today that really
believes that everything is possible and
you really own your own destiny as long
as you have a high level of
self-efficacy welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello hello and welcome to another
episode of 20 minute leaders today I'm
with Yuval Summit the CEO of rise up
ival is a product manager and
entrepreneur with a passion for solving
people's pains through value driven
products he co-founded analyzed a fraud
protection company which in 2011 was
acquired by clarna eval joined plarna
and there he built the clarana Tel Aviv
r d Center founded the product group as
Chief product officer and finally acted
as Chief technology officer after five
years at Clark 93 in Sweden he moved
back to Israel to build impact
technology products for Israelis in 2017
he founded rise up a profit with purpose
startup which uses Cutting Edge
technology to help middle and lower
income Israeli families control their
finances and start to save money he is
currently the CEO and he runs a product
leadership boot camp out of Tel Aviv
aimed to build the next generation of
product managers in Israel
thank you so much for joining me from
the rise up offices I'm so excited to
hear about your journey about this
journey of rise up to the industry
during the Insight that you've had and
and hear all about it so again thank you
very much for for spending this time
with me
tell me a little bit about yourself as
an entrepreneur even you know without
rise up who is your values taking part
in leadership roles in a variety of
organizations today you're the CEO of a
company
tell me a little bit about your
relationship with sort of the
entrepreneurial landscape
yeah so um honestly it is a little bit
difficult for me to track back when when
it actually started my um the
entrepreneurship bug I think it was
almost always there
um I think that I got
um you know the the present of believing
that everything is possible for my
mother and the present of creativity for
my father
um and you know growing up I've never
imagined that I would build a startup
because
um you know who knew what was a starting
back then 30 years ago I think
um but actually during the the high
school you know we used to write notes
to each other uh you know doing lessons
and uh one person that I studied with
gave me a call a few years back and told
me that she actually has a note from
when we were 15 years old
and I actually wrote her that until I
turned 30 years old I will build a
company with my brothers I will sell it
and then I will focus on social change
and to me it was mind-blowing I mean who
knew
um but I guess it is some some you know
somehow really ingrained in My DNA and
my my brothers are Financial Services
entrepreneurs as well so I think that it
is something about the small apartment
in in the town of beta that she really
taught us uh you know entrepreneurship
um and uh we we grew up you know with
the financial how cheap at home uh but
we did find that uh you know the path of
creativity and I think that our parents
really taught us how to impact others
um and our channel to do it is with
technology so
um I also think that you know my
personal story is a very Israeli story
you know growing up during the 80s uh to
parents that um uh you know my mother
was born in in a tent camp in marbara we
call it in Hebrew and my father came
from Poland and they did not have any
safety Network and you know they worked
really hard to provide us and educate us
and I think that um it really made me
believe that it doesn't matter in which
zip code you are born at it doesn't need
to dictate the trajectory of your life
and I think that you know it may be
maybe the entrepreneur I am today that
really believes that everything is
possible and you really own your own
destiny as long as you have a high level
of self-efficacy so you know when you
start the company it is sometimes hard
to admit that the company's story is
somewhat your own story but now when
rise up is five years old and we are
helping you know solving dozens of
thousands of people already I know that
my story is really a deep out of Isaac
yeah and you know and now I I admit it
uh in the early days of the company it
was much more difficult for me to admit
for some odd reason
uh but this is what was it that's called
to admit because it took time for you to
get to that understanding or that you
thought that it was contradictory in
some way what was the difficulty there I
did not want to put myself in the middle
um I think I did not want to be the rock
star ninja entrepreneur that you know
founder
that you know is really narcissistic
about his path and
um and I really believe in you know
um equality and empowerment when
building teams and I have co-founders
Tamala and iftaku are absolutely amazing
um and I really did not want it to be a
eval story and I still don't think rise
up is eval story but I do admit nowadays
that my own story is
you know deeply rooted in the company
and um you know building the technology
technology and brand and product and
service that helps people switch their
mindset from being concerned to being
confident about money I mean this is
exactly the path that I went through so
nowadays I admit it I don't have any
problem talking about it but it took me
quite a while to understand that it is a
core part of what the company is what
the product does and what our brand is
all about you know what I mean
100 okay so let's dive into to rise up
and take me to the to the to the problem
space that we're living in in the world
of of finance and opportunities
absolutely so uh let's do a quick
um you know a quick quiz so have you
ever eaten kale the green stuff
oh I love kale especially kale chips
there you go there you go do you like
quinoa
I love quinoa have you ever taken uh you
know an icy bath like Wim Huff
I did one just five days ago for the
first time I feel like I'm ruining the
quiz I don't know if I'm if I'm not I'd
give you good answers are wrong actually
your answer is oh brilliant look people
do crazy things nowadays in order to
reach well-being in their life to
achieve some head space you know I think
that um
um all of us are going through some sort
of PTSD post covered I mean you really
see that it impacted people not only the
economy our mental health as well so
people do a lot of different things in
order to achieve the headspace they need
in their life however people do very
little in order to achieve Financial
well-being which I claim is the basis
for well-being so rise up is all about
making it easy and enjoyable for anyone
to Achieve Financial well-being and the
way we do it is by connecting to your
bank account and credit card data
aggregating its slicing and dicing it
and identifying the things you should be
concerned about and helping you to
switch them to a point of confidence so
it is all about managing a positive cash
flow helping you making it even more
positive and then direct the surplus of
your cash flow to the right Financial
assets we are
um you know we are walking to be the
leaders of the financial well-being
Revolution that we believe is happening
because you can really see that
well-being touches upon so many
different domains nowadays from
education to health to
nutrition to sports however one domain
that is not yet disrupted by well-being
is financial services
still people that you know make a
reasonable salary that is how the end
find it really hard to build Financial
well-being on their own and this is what
we're all about we are doing it already
for dozens of thousands of people in
Israel and soon we are going to do it in
Europe as well
why is it so hard why what I mean we we
all know that managing our finances is
you know we do it poorly and we make
mistakes why is it so freaking hard I
mean it should be something as simple as
money and money out right I mean why why
is this such a
complicated subject for you know very
smart people all around the world to be
struggling with with especially when
it's a very you know a very personal one
it literally touches their own lives and
opportunities what's the challenge there
so I think that money is self-efficacy
it is merely um you know an objective
Financial issue
um being good with money and using money
as an enabler for a better life for
financial well-being and well-being at
large
um really is uh much more related to
whether you're optimistic towards the
challenge or not I mean most people
don't have the knowledge the access and
the humidity and passion and
perseverance to you know stay on the on
a certain path with a certain strategy
of the time we learned that people most
people live in scarcity uh when it comes
to money most people should rest about
money and it doesn't matter if they want
for uh you know a high-tech company or
they have a fantastic stable income
still they can experience in a mental
perspective money as a very stressful
thing and when people are stress uh the
uh the cortex goes to sleep the
rationale goes to sleep with it and you
become very emotional with your decision
making and then all the biases that walk
on our brain
um you know kick in the pleasant bias I
I prefer buying pizza now instead of
saving for the future and so on so to be
honest it makes it incredibly hard to be
good with money
um when um you know
um the Vanguard people have a saying
that I really like uh the the index fund
the the ones that invented the concept
of investing with an index
um they basically claim that in order to
be good with money you need to do two
things it most people most people really
suck at you need to be humble and learn
all the time and you need to to have a
strategy that you know you execute all
the time on those are the things that
human beings are usually not really good
at so I believe that the power of
Technology making it very easy the power
of a support Circle the community that
shows you people like you make it easier
and also you know entertaining content
that make it something that is not
painful to do those are the things that
you need to enable in order to help
people become better with money it is
not about but you know teaching them
it's not about financial literacy it's
about providing the tools that are
effective to enjoy uh the financial
services that are becoming really a
commodity because buying a money market
fund in order to offset inflation makes
a lot of sense for most people but most
people will not do it because a what is
a market a money market fund B how how
do you buy it see what are the tax
regulations and implications and so on
it just makes it makes it difficult and
there is a lot of friction with money so
I believe that these are the things that
really limit from people to you know be
on top of it and enjoy it and enable
well-being
but I first of all I love the insights
and um I personally am a huge fan of
Behavioral economics Game Theory and and
irrationality as it plays into the way
that we you know are you know I love how
you framed it at the beginning asking if
I didn't know we could take all these
crazy extravagant measures to try and
optimize for our well-being and our
headspace yes you know there's things in
our day-to-day that are hindering that
what insights over the last several
years running rise up have you learned
about people of humans that
that kind of how you can help all of us
right what are the different things that
you've understood that you're sort of
your key insights on the behaviors that
you're now employing through rise ups
that really are making a difference in
in helping people like us you know
manage our Our Lives better
so first of all the realization that uh
it's a self-efficacy uh challenge more
than an objective Financial issue right
really the core of the serial change of
our product activity model
so what really is self-efficacy and can
you build self-efficacy so the
psychologist bandura is the one that
um came up with the self-efficacy Theory
and he described four components that
build self-efficacy uh sense of support
sense of control individual success and
watching people like you succeed because
the way we learn as human beings is by
observing people like us so the
realization that you can really build
selfie efficacy is I think a fundamental
understanding of what we do over here at
taizer because then all the features
everything we do optimizes for building
self-efficacy so it becomes a flywheel
of you know Financial successes in order
to build your financial well-being let
me exemplify the things that are unique
unique realizations insights that you
really need to build the rise up in
order to understand so
um we look at a segment of customers
that are very successful with us
customers that are highly active and are
paying for a very long term and
attention in our service is super high
over time
um so when you look at those successful
customers you learn that they are a part
of our Facebook group what we call Our
Community people that participate in the
group customers paying customers that
participate in the group are three times
more likely to be successful so
participating in a community increases
the likelihood of success this is one
realization another Insight is
households that have two adults in the
household if both of them are members of
the service it increases the probability
of success by five times
right so wow interesting when you make
the financial issue the financial
challenge
um a couple thing you know you and your
spouse deal with it together it
increases the probability in such uh
High percentages so these are the type
of things that you will would never
consider as the main levels for being
successful
this is why I'm so enthusiastic about uh
Community as a whole thing that we do
um so we show people the uh data in in
our service how can they improve the you
know the cost of insurance and we create
a community challenge where they can
participate with hundreds and thousands
of people like them uh in order to uh
change the way they pay for insurance or
reduce the amounts so it makes it a
fantastic flywheel between my individual
story my story with my wife at home and
the story of the community which becomes
a significant level for change
I I absolutely I love it I love the
terminology that you're using and I they
I love the vision tell me a little bit
about yourself as a leader
well how how have you shaped uh as a
leader over these years as a CEO what
have you discovered about yourself
so you know when we started rise up uh
someone asked me what is the thing I
find
um most concerning when building a
company again
um and I quoted Patrick lancioni from
um you know the author of The Five
dysfunctions of a team which is really
the the Bible in my perspective of how
to build a team and how to enable
teamworld and he talks about it's not a
direct quote but he he speaks about uh
the fact that if you manage to put
anyone
um every team in a boat only in the same
direction you will win any competition
in any Market at any time and I think
that um you know building a team that is
aligned and feels empowered and inspired
to act on the mission of the company is
always the biggest challenge to keep uh
the the message coherent and to iterate
on it and to make sure that people you
know execute on the right stuff it is
always difficult so I think that though
always learning opportunities
um Italian or VPR and D just gave me
very honest feedback a couple of uh days
ago he told me look we need to do four
things for any you know squad leader you
in our company we need to inspire them
your data that we need to Mentor them
you do it really well as well but we
need to create more clarity and support
them better and you suck at both
you know as an experienced leader and
manager it was uh I was really happy to
to get this feedback because it shows
you how you can progress you can improve
all the time
so I think that as a leader I absolutely
respect the fact that whenever you build
the team even if it is the you know the
200 team that you build uh still you
need to invest as much in the teamwork
in order to make it work really well and
I think that we quite good at it at Liza
so as a leader I think that my theory of
how to build great companies through
fantastic teams still uh hold on and I
still have a lot to do to improve on it
I love it are you having fun
wow type 2 fun you know it's like
climbing a mountain
um in retrospective it is fun but the
hell chip while climbing is usually
quite uh significant so I do feel in my
flow there is a good match between the
skills I have to the challenges we meet
uh but I cannot say that you know every
day is 100 Fun uh we are doing difficult
things and we believe that everything is
possible so obviously it is not supposed
to be fun all the time but you know if
you are all about doing fun don't start
a company especially not in fintech
thank you so much this was so enjoyable
best of luck with rise up it was a
vision that you're putting in your
theory of change really awesome and I
can't wait to share this with the world
thank you thank you
[Music]